hi it's michelle of vlad muffin beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic chemist
and owner of a terrible teenage skincare
routine i talked about my teenage
skincare routine before go wash that if
you want all the gory details i have
oily acne prone and dehydration pro skin
and that skincare routine made
everything so much worse it took me
about 15 years to figure out a good
skincare routine we didn't have as much
skin care info on the internet back then
so today i'm going to be talking about
the skincare routine that i wish i had
if i was a teenager again i've included
a few alternatives for different skin
types and i've tried to keep everything
below 20 australian dollars i have
included a few things that tend to go on
sale a lot and with overseas products
the prices tend to fluctuate a bit and
remember these are my recommendations
they might not work for you if you have
other products that work really well for
you share them in the comments make sure
you like and subscribe if you like
science-based beauty content i'm going
to start with a thing not to have in
your routine and that is a mirror and
tweezers where you do homework
i have a few dental scars in my nose
here and between my eyebrows around here
if you look closely and those are from
digging blackheads out of my face when i
was 14. it is just too easy to
procrastinate by picking out your skin
if you have a mirror in the place where
you tend to procrastinate the most and a
magnifying mirror is even worse do not
get a magnifying mirror if someone gives
you a magnifying mirror it is a curse
re-gifted to a cousin you don't like so
let's go on to cleanses cleansing is
important and gentle cleansers are the
way to go clogged pores are one of the
things that you start having to deal
with when you reach your teenage years
unless you're one of those genetically
blessed people with no skin issues ever
and that is because sebum which is your
skin oil is actually one of the things
that clogs your pores sometimes your
body is just not a team player one of
the big components of sebum is guayline
which is also a skincare ingredient this
reacts with oxygen and in light and it
goes from runny to sticky and more solid
so this starts sticking dead skin cells
together to form little plugs in your
skin that clog your pores and these are
called microcomedones so cleansing
reduces the amount of sebum on your face
and gets rid of some of the stuff that's
already reacted and so that helps to
reduce clogged pores another good reason
to use a cleansing is really just the
feel cleansers get dirt and oil off your
skin as well as any skincare or makeup
products that you're using i talk a lot
more about choosing and using a good
cleanser in my ebook the lab muffin
guide to basic skin get but in short
stripping your skin with cleansing is
not a good approach you can't just bully
your skin into behaving it makes oily
skin feel worse and it irritates your
skin if you have acne prone skin that's
even worse because irritation is one of
the factors that contributes to acne
along with oil and lots of dead skin
cells which i mentioned before cleanses
with high ph can also disturb your skin
and make it easier for acne bacteria to
spread and really get ingrained into
your skin anyway i think a lot of people
especially people who are new to skin
care tend to underestimate how important
a good cleanser is because they wash off
so it seems like it doesn't have that
much of an impact it's only on your skin
for a short amount of time
but in reality a good cleanser can make
a massive difference so here are my
picks for budget friendly cleanses that
work well for acne prone skin a
disclaimer this video isn't sponsored
but i've been sponsored by some of these
brands in the past and i was sent
samples of a lot of these products but
these are my genuine recommendations i
really like the bioderma cleansing gels
they come in handy pumped tops and they
just work really well the bioderma cebum
cleansing gel is specifically made for
acne prone skin
it can be a little stripping if your
skin is dehydration prone so these days
i actually prefer the sensor bio gel
cleanser this is a bit more hydrating
but it is missing some of the actives
that the cbm cleanser has that can help
with oily acne prone skin another of my
favorites that you can get in stores in
australia is the bondi sands freshen up
gel cleanser this is also launching
worldwide it's really gentle fragrance
free and very no frills the harder labo
gokujin cleanser and the hamish all
clean green foam are also really gentle
very similar sort of idea but they foam
a bit more a few more supermarket picks
the neutrogena ultra gentle daily
cleanser the cetaphil oily skin cleanser
the cerave hydrating cleanser and the
van cleanance gel if you're australian
and you're after an in-store option i'd
also check out the azcle foaming
cleanser and the qv gentle skin cleanser
so cleansing you should probably do this
about once or twice a day
how much you want to cleanse really
depends on your skin i've personally
found that cleansing once a day at night
is a lot better than cleansing twice a
day because my skin is so dehydration
prone cleansing too much just tends to
dry it out but that might be different
for you just feel free to experiment
with the frequency okay onto makeup
removal now i wasn't allowed to wear
makeup to school so i didn't really need
this but these days i love doing a
double cleanse i didn't know what that
was back then basically cleansing oils
and cleansing balms are products that
you can use to melt away makeup really
easily and they also work really well
for water resistant sunscreen it just
sort of gets rid of everything before
you go in with another cleanser now the
annoying thing with cleansing oils is
that they can be a bit expensive and
difficult to find the one that was
easiest to find was the simple kind to
skin cleansing all but unfortunately it
looks like it's been discontinued there
is the qv bath oil in australia which
wasn't made to be a cleansing oil but it
works pretty well for that it does leave
behind a bit of residue though so you'll
want to follow up with a regular
cleanser the korean brand etude house
also has cleansing oils that sometimes
go on sale cleansing balms are solid
versions that are a bit easier to use
but they also tend to be a bit expensive
the cheapest options that i've tried and
loved are the ordinary squarelink
cleanser and the hamish all clean balm
if you're looking for a simpler
cleansing routine and you wear makeup or
waterproof sunscreen i would recommend a
micellar water you can use this as a
single product to remove makeup and
clean your skin simple have a really
good budget-friendly micellar water
bioderma is also fantastic i'd recommend
the sensor bio one over the sebium
because you can't use the sebium around
your eyes both of these have been
through a lot of clinical testing to
make sure they're really gentle and they
can be left on skin without rinsing for
most people without issues so it's
really good for after sports or if
you're just too tired to get to a sink
i'd also grab some reusable cotton pairs
to use with these cheaper disposable
cotton pads tend to be a bit rough on
skin i actually used to use some that
made me think that the micellar water
was too harsh for my skin for a long
time and yeah i'm not really that smart
i just play a smart person on tv most
brands of reusable cotton pads last for
ages you can also make some diy ones if
you're a bit crafty now on to acne
treatments there are a few common
over-the-counter options that are good
for dealing with acne but it's important
to remember as dr angeli mantra said in
our collaboration on food and acne
if you've given these over-the-counter
options a good bash and your acne
doesn't seem to be getting better and
this is an option that's available to
you it is a good idea to talk to a
doctor or dermatologist sometimes what
looks like acne is something else
sometimes acne comes from internal
causes that over-the-counter products
just can't really fix if your acne is
extending onto the rest of your body if
it's starting to scar or affect your
mental health these are good signs that
you should probably move on to
professional help let's start with the
most famous acne ingredient benzoyl
peroxide it is famous for a good reason
it is really effective at killing acne
bacteria and it does it in a way that
doesn't promote bacterial resistance in
other words as you're attacking the
bacteria the bacteria doesn't just
evolve and get even stronger which is
not a good situation benzoyl peroxide
also decreases clogged pores so it deals
with baby pimples that haven't become
full-blown pimples yet it is pretty
harsh and drying though so you'll
probably need a gentle cleanser and a
good moisturizer and it does tend to
work better when you use it all over
your face preventatively rather than as
a spot treatment after the pimple has
already well and truly left the station
my favorite type of benzoyl peroxide
product is a benzoyl peroxide cleanser
benzoyl peroxide is really annoying
because it does tend to stain things it
bleaches stuff it reacts with dyes and
fabric and it tends to
wander off your face onto things that
you really want to stay coloured so
things like pillowcases and towels and
shirts be really careful about what
you're using when you start using
benzoyl peroxide because chances are
your favorite shirt is going to get
ruined having the benzoyl peroxide in a
cleanser means that most of it will go
down the drain before that happens but
it is best to just be a bit careful wear
some old clothes at first if you're
using a benzoyl peroxide cleanser i
would recommend that you also have a
gentle cleanser as well because you
probably don't want to use the benzoyl
peroxide every day because yeah it can
really dry out your skin some popular
options are benzac ac wash which has 5
benzoyl peroxide and neutrogena clear
poor cleanser mask which has 3.5
when you use these you want to apply it
to your face and then wait about a
minute before you wash it away so that
that benzoyl peroxide has time to sink
into your skin and work these benzoyl
peroxide cleansers are also really handy
if you have acne on your body so you can
avoid stains on your clothes it can also
act as a deodorant if you use it on your
armpits because it kills the bacteria in
your armpits that causes the stink if
you want to use a leave-on benzoyl
peroxide product there's research
showing that 2.5 works as well as 10
with less irritation so go for the lower
percentage don't get sucked in by the
higher number and remember to put it on
all over so that it prevents future
pimples prevention is a lot easier than
treatment the second ingredient i
recommend for acne is salicylic acid
this is also known as beta hydroxy acid
and it acts as an exfoliant it helps
your dead skin cells shed more evenly
and that means it prevents clogged pores
and blackheads it keeps your pores
clearer and so they look less obvious
generally chemical exfoliants will just
smooth out your skin a bit it will
reduce some of that skin texture now the
problem with salicylic acid products is
that a lot of the good ones tend to be a
bit more expensive 0.5 to 2
is a good concentration for most people
the cheapest product i could find is the
revolution skincare 2 salicylic acid
tonic which is 20 for a 200 ml bottle my
favorite one actually isn't too bad it's
the paula's choice one which comes in a
mini 30 ml bottle for 15
which is surprisingly cheaper than the
inky list and revolution 30 mil ones for
australians at least
and i think it is just a much better
formula alternatively you could get the
118 ml bottle for 42. which works out to
be about one-third cheaper per ml the
way i use this is i pour a little bit
into my hand and then i spread it all
over my face with my fingers you can
also just rub your hands together and
then press it into your skin as well
some people like to apply these with a
cotton pad but to me it feels like i am
wasting product there is also azoleic
acid
azolic acid isn't my favorite ingredient
it seems to work for a lot of conditions
according to studies but it also just
doesn't really seem to be super
effective at any one thing
and the texture of azelaic acid products
is
kind of tacky and thick and gloopy but
azelaic acid is generally less
irritating than a lot of other active
ingredients so i thought i'd mention it
two options in australia are as clear
and phoenicia i do also want to mention
alpha hydroxy acids even though you have
an exfoliant in the beta hydroxy acid
the salicylic acid i've personally found
that with texture and whiteheads alpha
hydroxyaces tend to work a lot better my
budget-friendly picks for this would be
the ordinary's glycolic acetone which is
a little bit strong
it is a bit spicy on a lot of people's
skin so be careful with this don't use
it every day maybe mix it in with
something else so you don't use as much
there's also the ordinary's lactic acid
products these are a bit gentler lactic
acid in general is a bit gentler than
glycolic acid because the molecules are
larger so they don't get into the skin
as deeply onto a product that i really
wish i knew about when i was in high
school hydrocolloid pimple patches these
are little stickers that you stick onto
pimples and they soak up the liquid and
pass inside the pimples i've personally
found that they seem to work a little
bit better on inflamed pimples you can
also use them over intact pimples but i
personally feel like they work better
after i've stabbed the pimple with a
sterile lance i'm not sure if that's
just me being superstitious and i feel
like there's a tunnel so the liquid can
get out better but i have another video
on how to pop a pimple safely so check
that out if you
tend to pop your pimples and you can't
really stop the main thing i like about
these pimple patches is that they stop
you from picking out your pimples any
further plus sealing in the moisture
helps them heal a bit faster the most
budget-friendly option is to buy
something like a duradome bandage and
cut it up into little bits they can be a
bit chunky though and they can just sort
of leap off your face at awkward moments
if you move around too much like in the
middle of a sentence
so you probably only want to use these
at nighttime or if you're at home and
you're not really seeing anyone there
are also flatter versions that are
specifically made for pimples and these
are great because you can wear them
during the day and they're not super
obvious if your skin is raw it's really
hard to get makeup and concealer to sit
on it properly so if you have the right
color patch it disguises the pimple so
it's a lot less noticeable you can also
just go completely the other way and use
the pimple patches that look like stars
if that's more your style cosrx have
some really cheap ones there's also hero
cosmetics who have mighty patch and one
of the versions has tapered edges which
makes it blend in really nicely on your
face i think most countries also have
local versions of these pimple patches
in australia there's the very originally
named pimple patch
we are a simple people here so remember
if you've tried a few options and it
didn't really help or if your acne is
quite severe and causing scarring go see
a doctor you can also do this if you
just want to skip all this trial and
error and cut straight to the higher
risk higher reward options now sunscreen
if you've been on the internet you will
probably know that every skin care
person says sunscreen is super important
and it is it's really important for
protecting your skin from uv uv is
linked to skin cancer and premature
aging the uv can break down collagen
which is what keeps your skin bouncy so
it's a good idea to get into the habit
of wearing sunscreen every day if you're
going out into the sun for acne prone
skin sunscreen is especially good for
preventing post inflammatory
hyperpigmentation
this is where after your skin's been
traumatized such as after a pimple it
starts to just pump out extra brown
pigment and so you get this little patch
of brown you get a little dark spot and
this can take months to go away this
happens more if you have melanated skin
that is used to being good at producing
brown pigment the problem is that it can
be hard to get into the habit of wearing
sunscreen daily a lot of sunscreens feel
heavy and greasy so if you haven't used
a lot of skincare before then this can
be a lot to adjust to so the best
sunscreen for you is the sunscreen that
you'll wear consistently and at the
right amount and lots of studies have
shown that the nicer the texture of a
sunscreen the more likely it is that
you'll wear it consistently so generally
what you're looking for in a sunscreen
is firstly a suitable spf rating
generally over 30 is recommended and the
higher the number the more protection
you get if the amount of uv isn't that
high where you are spf 15 might be
enough you also want good uva protection
uva is a type of uv that's more strongly
linked to hyperpigmentation to get good
uva protection it's a bit more confusing
because depending on where in the world
you are it's labeled differently so
you're looking for broad spectrum or the
uva circle logo or pa with three or four
pluses or a high ppd number or more
stars in the boot star rating i have a
lot of other videos about sunscreens if
you want more details on how to choose
and use them but here are some popular
budget-friendly lightweight sunscreens
that might help you start on your
sunscreen journey biore skin aqua watery
essence is a japanese sunscreen that's
sold in a lot of online stores that ship
to lots of countries it's super popular
and works for a lot of people because it
has such a lightweight refreshing feel
and it sits well under makeup it's
designed to feel watery bondi sans
fragrance free lotion is a cheaper
option that's not quite as lightweight
but it's available in lots of countries
including the us uk and australia
there's a body and a face version and
most people seem to agree that they feel
pretty much the same it also has four
hours water resistance so you can use it
for beach days as well if you're in
australia i'd also recommend trying the
two dollar sunscreens that you can get
in woolworths and kohl's and audi these
are meant to be body sunscreens but
they're actually quite nice in texture
and they're super budget friendly so if
they don't work for your face they
should be fine for your body they're
also four hours water resistant the
natio daily defense and the cancer
council matte face are also really
popular australian sunscreens they work
well under makeup but some people do
complain about their eyes stinging a bit
with these
so with application the amount you want
to apply is about a quarter teaspoon for
your face or two generous ish finger
lengths of sunscreen more is more when
it comes to sunscreen the more you use
the better the protection you have so
don't skimp on sunscreen don't mix it
with anything apply it generously don't
forget to reapply it if you're getting
more sun exposure these things are
usually written on the label as well so
check that for specific instructions
and don't forget there are other ways
you can also protect yourself from the
sun don't stay in the sun for too long
wear some protective clothing like hats
and sunglasses now on to moisturizers
i have personally never really had a
good time with the standard super
budget-friendly bulk moisturizers that a
lot of people tend to recommend i'm
talking about things like cerave
cetaphil and qv which is like the
australian version of these and just saw
bling cream these tend to come in really
big pump bottles or in really big tubs
they do work for a lot of people so i'd
recommend giving them a try especially
if you have drier skin or if you live in
a cool dry climate but for me these tend
to feel a bit greasy they feel like
they're sitting on the surface of my
skin and not really sinking in and they
clog my pores so if you've tried these
and you don't like them but you still
feel like your skin needs a moisturizer
here are some lighter options it's
actually a bit difficult to find lighter
moisturizers that still hydrate well
from western drugstore brands but bondi
sands recently launched two moisturizers
that are really lightweight and
hydrating they're also fragrance free
neutrogena hydro boost also has
moisturizers that are really good
options but they are fragrance which can
be a problem if you're sensitive to
fragrance asian skincare brands tend to
have really good lightweight
moisturizers but
there are very few of them that are
consistently below 20 australian dollars
one that i've tried and seems to work
for a lot of people and stays around the
20 mark is the iunic cintella calming
cream this has centella which is great
for soothing irritated skin you can also
try slugging if you want this is where
you put a thick layer of vaseline over
your face while you sleep so you can
live the slug life
i'd be a little cautious about this for
acne prone skin because while petroleum
jelly by itself
isn't very good at clogging your pores
it can potentially help your other
products irritate more so proceed with
caution but it is a very cheap thing to
try that can work really well for dry
weather now if you're a bit of a skin
picker like i was when i was a teenager
and i still am sometimes i'd also
recommend the la roche posay cica plus
balm this is a really nice hydrating
almost ointment like thick cream that's
really good for protecting your skin
when it's raw and peeling i used to pick
off flakes of skin with tweezers and i'd
end up with these raw patches of skin on
my face and this just really calms that
sort of thing down a cheap alternative
for this is again vaseline i don't find
that it works quite as well because it
doesn't have those extra actives so i've
linked all of these budget friendly
recommendations in the description i've
also linked a few other videos that you
might be interested in there's one on
hyperpigmentation and how to deal with
it especially those dark post acne marks
if there are some really great products
that i've missed let me know in the
comments also like and subscribe you can
follow me on instagram and tick tock and
check out my blog and i will see you
next time for more beauty science